we start today's program in turkey where
a lot of people are currently facing a
difficult time because of surging prices
the new year begins with long queues for
bread which is at least still affordable
fruit meat and fish have become luxury
goods for many turks
vendors are stuck with their perishable
products their customers are forced to
budget their liras tightly the currency
is rapidly losing its value it's a cause
of anger for many in turkey
and most of that anger is directed at
him turkish president recep tayyip
erdogan many blame him for the drastic
plunge of the lira they are worried that
erdogan's economic policies will be the
financial ruin of many turks the
inflation is particularly hard on the
country's poorest
people like embracer he's a waste
material collector even before the
current crisis it was difficult for him
to make ends meet and now he barely
earns enough to feed his young family
an old cardboard box means hard cash for
emra hazir
the 25 year old earns money by
collecting waste paper from garbage cans
in istanbul a metropolis with a
population of over 15 million he also
collects plastic
it's hard to make a living because in
times of economic crisis the prices of
recyclable materials are plummeting
a kilo of cardboard gets you the
equivalent of three euro cents a kilo of
plastic only 10 cents instead of 12
cents
every day emra spends 10 hours wandering
the streets of istanbul in search of
paper and plastic he's just one of
thousands of collectors of recyclable
materials struggling to survive in
turkey
the price of bread has gone up again
even the price for the cheapest bread
has doubled
how can i afford enough food
but i have to keep working
a derelict building on the outskirts of
the city serves as a collection point
where emra delivers his findings at the
end of the day
he collected 58 kilos today and earned
the equivalent of less than 5 euros
after sorting the garbage is later
transported to recycling plants
the streets would be full of litter
we prevent the garbage cans from
overflowing
that was true up until now but in the
midst of the economic crisis of all
times turkish authorities plan to let
private companies collect recyclables
it's a lucrative market as a result the
mostly illegal collection points will
disappear
a few months ago an eviction order led
to violent clashes between waste
collectors and the police
there were dozens of arrests
meanwhile the recyclables workers have
joined forces to fight back against the
allegations
they say that we employ illegal refugees
we pose a security problem in
residential neighborhoods
and we disturb the peace of local
residents
in a press statement
the governor of istanbul
called on citizens to work together to
ensure that the carts of waste
collectors disappear from the streets
amra has to share his living space in
istanbul with three other collectors
they all come from the far east of
turkey
he only sees his wife and one-year-old
child every three months
sometimes i sit here and i wish i could
be home with them
but i can't
my mother just called the other day
and said they don't have money for
diapers so i know i have to keep going
here
the next morning emra sends clothes and
toys home to his family with a relative
he found the toys in the trash
but it's not only the country's
estimated 500 000 garbage collectors who
are currently fearing for their
livelihoods
the value of the turkish lira has almost
halved in the past year and inflation is
officially at 36 percent
economic experts say it's actually much
higher
in surveys more than half of the
population say they can barely afford
their daily groceries
almost three quarters of turks are in
debt
and almost everyone complains about a
drop in income
these figures show how desperate the
situation is
at the collection point operations
continue but for how much longer
emra and his colleagues hope the
government will hold off in changing the
recycling system for a while longer
collecting and sorting recyclables is a
very complex matter
and difficult to organize
after all
there is no waste separation in turkish
households
so for now emra is still needed on the
streets of istanbul but every day the
economic situation worsens
and for emra that means he must collect
even more garbage to make ends meet
you